in 2013 Alexander Dario was announced as
a cast member on HBO's new Anthology
series True Detective The Season's cast
included veterans like Matthew mccon
Woody harelson and Michelle Monahan
although didario had shared the screen
with numerous A-list stars in the past
she felt some pressure when she joined
the HBO series she told Esquire I always
have a bit of trepidation before I start
anything just because I want to do well
you want to do a great job and you want
to impress people however she also kept
her expectations in check during the
filming of this inaugural season didario
wasn't sure if the show was even going
to be well received let alone go down in
TV history as one of the best seasons of
any show ever so she just treated the
role the same as any other job she
didn't become close with any of the cast
either being that she wasn't onset much
due to her limited role thankfully this
didn't harm her overall experience as
she explained to Esquire having dinner
with somebody you've looked up to your
whole life is quite a memorable thing